yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
the governor of Hulu now here's some
stuff I'm going to
do okay Hulu is going to buy Honey Boo
Boo and put it on
Voodoo no boo boo on Hulu we're going to
mix Star Wars with Transformers now oh
Luke Skywalker he turns into an ice
cream truck in the Yoda he says give me
all the ice cream you know the ice cream
I would like to have ice cream to give
it to me then Luke Skywalker he can say
no we have to save ice cream for chupaca
here's another thing very important
we're going to do here at Hulu it's
called the dooo review at Hulu so what
you're going to do here is all the
employees have to take a picture of the
[__] and then the Hulu dooo AI they
decide who gets fired